well it looks dark what's different
nothing all right we're on okay right
with the lighting now maybe it's about
right yeah it looks real dark for a
second I guess it was some kind of
screensaver I don't know uh hey you guys
um we just decided to do because we're
gonna do like um for the 200th episode
we decided we were gonna do a live
stream if this works out we might do it
tomorrow night or Saturday night
probably like Eastern Standard Time
tomorrow's Friday yeah yeah do you want
to do it tomorrow night or it doesn't
matter to be yeah we wanted so we can do
it then so I just wanted to kind of do
hey we got somebody hey hey hey what's
up guys I can't read it would you say we
got armed ASMR oh yeah yeah okay lay
there anyway to be online we had a Noel
Sahay
yeah hopefully we'll have monetization
hooked up by then so you guys can
[ __ ] donate and [ __ ] yeah cuz like I
said I really didn't have much of any
idea hi Nico hi Jake I yeah I didn't
really know how this was gonna work and
like I said I didn't really want to get
into doing the episode and then have it
not do anything correctly so I figured
we could probably just do like we do on
the sidetrack show you know what I mean
since we can't just like sit here
monsters get decide stop propaganda says
hey your life yes we are yeah so hey if
any of you guys have any questions you
want to ask us we can answer them now is
your time isn't that time I didn't think
anybody beyond here actually
hey Zachary yes we didn't do it we
didn't really do any announcement I just
well I just announced it on Facebook and
stuff it's like I said this was it you
know this wasn't like a super plan thing
I was just this is like just a technical
writing over it I was like Matt no give
him a notification you an hour give him
like an hour to get ready cuz there's a
way to do it do you see how to do it now
well yeah I guess but it's like you all
you do is you I mean you mark to like
start it later but then it just started
now anyway so I'm not really sure yeah I
figured out the light today yeah it does
look actually kind of nice
yeah look in here on the damn screen it
looks awful dark but you know longest
you guys say it's good we'll keep it
like that yeah cuz it's hard to tell
like I mean this seems to be working so
that's really good I was like afraid
that my Mac wouldn't like we're not sure
about buffering issues and how much you
know how much of this video data we can
[ __ ] send down to this old laptop
yeah that's why that's why I'm kind of
like worried about the episode because
if we go on for like hours and hours
yeah we don't know if it's just [ __ ]
sending it directly to the cloud or if
it's building up inside that CPU we
don't know yeah yeah because we do a
really long show when we're recording a
really long show it's starting there
starts to lag yeah well when I'm
recording it another quarter I don't
know it's the same I think that might be
just because I mean I use some like just
cheap-ass you know program because that
I can't really afford a good one so I
think talking yeah well good we have a
question okay do you all have any advice
about anger management
I swear road rage nearly kills me and a
guy yelled [ __ ] you to me from his car
earlier and I followed him home and
about kicked his door yes I've done this
always pact he just talk [ __ ] you jump
around through the window [ __ ] reach
in and grab and pull him out button beat
the [ __ ] out in front of everybody walk
off like a man like that be fine yeah do
you know what I did one time I don't
know if I ever said this on the show
right this is a long time this is when I
still lived in Daytona Beach I was
driving to either driving to work or
drive to the mall or something [ __ ] like
that and I'm driving and there was these
bunch of kids and they were like on the
side of the road and they were throwing
rocks at cars just because I guess
that's what you do when you're again
dumbass so they threw rocks at my car
and like the car like it didn't [ __ ] it
up but it like you know dented the side
or it went under the wheel well or
something like that and I was like so so
mad that I just like made a u-turn like
in the middle of the road it wasn't like
a real crowded road or anything and I
then I went into the dirt like and just
started driving right after they would
have like jumped over the wall I'm like
that's I didn't get hurt any of them or
anything I just scared him I was like
see that's what just don't do that again
then well I'm glad that you guys could
tell the difference in the lights
because we got two new RG B's there
behind the there behind the lab till
laptop being a soft bounce off the wall
once purple and once kind of this last
magenta magenta yeah once magenta and
the other one's kind of aquam values
like death trying to get us a little bit
more depth in our faces you know what I
mean because without lighting you just
look like a [ __ ] real flat [ __ ]
corpse yeah with bad circles underneath
your eyes and that's not really how you
look in person it's just on camera
[ __ ] when the Lighting's wrong I
think yeah I think so too on the camera
damn we look like [ __ ]
I know right well yeah sometimes like
every now and then like I'll take a
picture and I'll just be like oh that
looks like a good picture but it's like
the the pictures that I think like look
the pastor wants that looks like yeah no
that's not true so yeah we got bloody
hell your live she just sent us she just
sent us and her just sent us some PayPal
donation yeah what I think it was yeah
yeah
so what let's see what did we watch last
night oh okay so I think we're gonna do
a matinee video on this even though it's
not super new like I think it was made
in 2017 but it didn't come out till 2019
we saw the velocity why so faster was
good I like it was delightful yeah it
was a delightful memory it was better
than Ouija shark it was a lot better it
was a lot more self-aware yeah I feel
like and vilasa faster is a good movie
in the way that bloodsport is a good
movie in the way that under siege to is
a good movie it's like that kind of
movie it was kind of like you know you
know what I was talking about we just
shark and I was like if you have um you
know I liked that movie but if you have
a premise that absurd you need to lean
into it okay this one
does like this one knows exactly like
how ridiculous the [ __ ] is yeah and it
just like goes for it and it's it's also
got lips looks really kind of goofy
charm to it it was like it was lovable
makes fun of its own [ __ ] special
effects there's a scene where they on
purpose forget to leave out the special
yeah again a guy's reacted to it it just
says written down their burning car yeah
I was like yeah I was reading there was
a AV Club did like a really long like
right up on it and they're talking about
just how [ __ ] like awesome it is and
somebody in the comments said oh they
should do a sequel to this and it sent
like at the end of the world but it
should be called Velociraptor you know
what I mean like and then like somebody
that for somebody underneath that
commented it's like I watch that hell
everyone would watch that and indeed
they would but yeah everyone should see
philosoph astir it's actually we watched
it free on to be it's got like a couple
ads but that's kind of a saw PT wheat
straw PT wheat straw does double
son-in-law that is also on TV that's
like if that's a old one that's Rudy ray
Moore your uh you know dolomite very
famously yeah ruga movie that one was
super fun I think that we can see where
Eddie Murphy got a lot of his
inspiration from yeah kind of like
prototype Eddie Murphy movies yeah you
know [ __ ] and evidently there I gotta
get coming to America again I haven't
seen it a long time I remember like in
that movie and there's an evidently a
sequel to it's coming up a sequel really
yeah with most of the original cast I'll
allow it
yeah but yeah so Petey wheat straw I
think I've like dozed off and you know
cuz I've been up since yeah you know so
I was like I was up at 5:30 yesterday
morning so I was like [ __ ] exhausted
but yeah basically PT wheat straw who
played by Rudy ray Moore he he like
makes a deal with the devil hey first of
all now you gotta start how it starts
that [ __ ] was born at 10 years of age
yeah that's right he jumped out a [ __ ]
he's 10 years old
and it scared the damn preacher away
remember who's trying to give birth it's
funny because the devil was already
involved with his parents were like
surprisingly lackadaisical yeah they
were just kind of like oh wow Tigers oh
he's already talking he was 10 years old
I think in a diaper on yeah yeah there's
all kinds of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] also
somebody shits their pants in this yeah
like hopefully he makes a deal with the
devil and gets a damn magic wand from
the devil and has the devil's power and
one gets involved with gangsters and
ends up being like Savior of the damn
hood and all kinds of cool [ __ ] happens
in it like the movie I did too it's a
lot of fun I like I think it was
actually a little maybe a little bit
more fun than Dolomites even just
because it had that supernatural like
devil element and hey everybody running
around with a little devil horns yeah
that was the bunch of demons and all the
demons wearing leotards and short capes
they look like this they look like the
[ __ ] demons out of them what was that
a [ __ ] Orange Julius they're like ah
nineteen sixties oars julienne style
devil yeah we did we used to have one we
didn't have one in our good mall but we
had one in our like you know kind of
crap all down I think people are saying
stuff they are oh well there's a couple
questions because we like went off on
these things yeah somebody asked if
somebody says ladies show on the Memphis
three was amazing thank you very much
somebody asked if you had ever thought
about writing down any of your stories
because you have so many awesome ones
like about your life and stuff yeah
maybe maybe if someday yeah but you
think is is that you you can't write
that kind of [ __ ] to you're already like
an old man and you're getting ready to
check out that [ __ ] like yeah oh say Oh
somebody says a philosopher now go see
killer sofa I haven't seen killer sofa
however I have seen the bed that eats
yeah kind of stuck it really was like
not as funny as I was hoping it would it
actually wasn't really funny at all like
other than a couple of scene that was a
home made movie you know it was yeah I
think it didn't get released until long
after it was made yeah something like
that I remember like reading something
of its got like a fascinating guy I
spent a long a long time making it he
just kind of pieced it together over the
years as he came across money that's how
I remembered that movie and the movie
didn't really make sense is well I
thought the weird thing about it is that
if you have if you have a premise like
death bed the bed that eats which is
probably like the best movies idol of
all time I have to say again you need to
lean into the ridiculousness but it
seems like this guy almost wanted to
make like a pretentious or yeah movie it
didn't work like about a person eating
bed but I was like you can't those two
things don't go together you can't
really - it wasn't that good there was
one I think there was one that came out
recently I haven't seen it yet but I
think it's called rubber that's
essentially about a killer tire you know
what I mean yeah I mean I feel I haven't
seen it but it's like um you know this
feels like trauma and stuff like that
they have all these things like you know
monstered and all that kind of stuff
where you know they just take like a
seemingly innocuous object and make a
horror movie out of it just like the
best thing I've seen it was the best
thing I've seen recently was turbo kid
yeah that was actually the best thing
recently oh yeah I like that one to be a
lot actually yeah we saw that on what
shutter there's more calm yes yours yeah
blue arrow scroll down yeah I'm going I
think they must be saying all conscious
yet
you guys should review fatal attraction
yes you probably yeah Tom needs to get
closer to the microphone okay man look
Vande nicole says she's seen she's seen
rubber it's like ridiculous but
hilarious sable attractions been
reviewed a lot though watch this why
should we review it yeah but I mean
we've reviewed a lot of movies that have
been reviewed a lot so I mean if if that
was the case we'd probably never review
anything I remembered like in the movie
but I'm not sure a movie like I'm not
sure that movie would hold up I'd have
to see it again I haven't seen it in a
really long time because when fatal
attraction came out I remember it I was
there big spate of movies that were
trying to kind of take off on that theme
came out they got sick of it
yeah I'm one of the ones we should
probably review it'd be [ __ ]
fear was denier I would like yeah that's
a good movie I like that we should do we
should review both of them like they're
we're doing the remake yeah okay
somebody asks where's Pookie Pookie is
running around here somewhere is she
outside or she you know ed no she's
inside she might be out on the back
porch she's inside so she is inside you
guys you know what Beijing or other cat
you know cuz remember I said on the show
before how she always like leaves these
little stuffed animals because I have
all these stuffed animals on the shelves
back there and she comes in in the
middle of the night and like arranges
them like around the house for whatever
reason it's like this morning she left a
perfect circle yeah of little stuffed
animals yeah they were nowhere else just
like in a circle she was telling me
about I didn't see it but she was
telling me about it dawned on me I was
like man it's like said my poltergeist
would do which kind of backs up you know
some of the stuff that I believe what a
poltergeist is I believe is just a part
of a human mind that does it a lot of
the [ __ ] that it did was kind of
animalistic
I'm just making patterns and [ __ ] you
know the men like why would why would a
human intelligence do that yeah yeah
it's more like something an animal would
do like cat Intel I would love to know
what's going on at Beijing his mind when
she that because yesterday when I got up
in the morning she had brought out like
hope we call him her babies and she had
brought out a whole bunch of the babies
and she was sitting by her little like
she has like a little cat thrown
scratchy thing and she was sitting right
next to that and she had like all these
babies like around her and she was just
like sitting in the middle like she was
like holding court because she talks to
them you know when she just does that in
the middle of the night yeah she doesn't
usually do that in the daytime unless
everyone is gone like unless or unless
she thinks the house is empty
yeah she's embarrassed of it because if
you catch her she just like looks away
like no and I know it's funny sometimes
that we've like come across her doing it
like if she thought no one was home and
so she was doing it if you find her
doing it she looks like really yeah yeah
she looks like she shamed of it yeah
even though it's like the cutest I don't
know why she would be embarrassed but
yeah she's like I'm not talking to them
she's pretending
yeah I think she's pretending like stop
it I know they're not real yeah I know
she's pretending and she gets kind of
embarrassed that she's pretending I
think I wish that we had a night-vision
camera because I would love to watch her
carry
all of the little babies out here like
one by one like in her mouth yeah
because this morning she brought out the
one the UM the Bride of Frankenstein
which is back there and look how big
that is that's like what that's pretty
big like for her little bitty kitty
mouth and I would have just loved to
seeing her get up there and get it and
then be carried with this big Bride of
Frankenstein stick it out of her mouth
that have been so hilarious any more
comments um somebody asked if you had
played fallout 76 no I hadn't played it
I played was it four and three and four
which one's Fallout New Vegas yeah
that's right I forgot to played that one
too yeah yeah I played New Vegas yeah
and then on the old ones I played most
of like two add-ons I think I played all
of them from three and most of them from
[ __ ] New Vegas I think but I haven't
and I've only four four four I've only
played I just got done with the new code
world okay but I'm gonna do that one
thing is called far harbour I'm gonna do
that one next but I had some other ships
I had to do in there um I'm right now
I'm getting back on Mad Max yeah I
finished a good game yeah I finished
everything from the game it's just I'm
trying to find all the scavenging
locations you know I mean there's a lot
of little you got to go everywhere and
somewhere somewhere hidden yeah even
though you might have a survey crew
it'll tell you where it is you can't get
to it
there you know it did tunnels and [ __ ]
like that you gotta find the entrance
and I was doing some stuff away out in
the desert there's a big desert stuff
but I got all the cars and I wanted
there to be an add-on to the tomb at
backs that's a good one
but there's no add-ons to it huh kind of
dumb that is dumb because I was a lot of
people like that game I've seen like a
lot of really good got pretty good
reviews but they just never made any
more for it I don't know why maybe they
just figured hey that was like that was
our best effort and like boomer it was
kind of repetitive when I came to the
basis the bases were all about kind of
the same that was that was one of the
problems with it but once the bases are
gone there's a lot of [ __ ] you can do
you know you find in stuff it's just uh
yeah I don't know I don't know why they
came out with an add-on yeah I buy it
you know but they didn't Beijing and
Pookie need their own show somebody says
yeah play dead space or alien isolation
why just because they're disgust I don't
know somebody's isolation I remember
that one that one's yeah so that's a
cool looking game I'm seeing that looks
pretty good I don't think you actually
fight the alien in that though do you
think you just avoid it
oh I don't know I would avoid it too if
it was me it was expensive I can't I
can't fight when it first came out I
think it was like 70 bucks holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah Tom we need Dennis that's so
cool there is Dennis right there yeah
Connors Bassem you're [ __ ] around
with Tom his video games he doesn't know
the [ __ ] he's talking about
I can play Tom's ass though oh my god no
you take a picture of like you play the
game and like you know him next to you
with like a little bit Xbox kicking my
ass on Halo [ __ ] you know multiplayer
I totally forgot to put up a show I
totally forgot to put up a Dennis sexual
problems today like I was in there
making some other Instagram cards and I
was like oh [ __ ] man I forgot to put up
Dennis 18 I gotta find another quote
I've been going through that book that
Sophie gave me with like all the Dennis
Rader's boys in it and like trying to
find funny ones yeah cuz he said like
some really weird [ __ ] man so if he
wants to come back for a visit
yeah it's like opens up yeah so maybe
sometime this summer yeah you know what
I mean oh you know what you guys it's
like do you remember like a long time
ago when I said how excited I was
because my sister had got me tickets to
see Nick Cave in October in Atlanta and
I was gonna good cuz she lives in
Atlanta and I was gonna go up there and
visit her and go see Nick Cave and
everything like that and the show just
got cancelled yeah a couple weeks ago
well I thought maybe because it wasn't
until October that maybe like all the
European ones were cancelled obviously
because they were supposed to go on in
the spring but like I was like hoping
it's like well no probably but they just
announced that we're gonna cancel it so
[ __ ] no I don't know what
this is the second time that I was going
to see Nick Cave and the [ __ ] got
canceled him back the first time I was
gonna go see him was like the
Lollapalooza that he was at I think it
was 1994 and I had tickets for it and it
was in [ __ ] it was in DeLand of all
places like which is between if you're
not from Florida it's like halfway in
between Orlando and Daytona Beach which
is so it was like close because that's
where a big fairground is and they were
having the fairground and then like the
night before the show there was like
this huge huge thunderstorm because
Florida and the whole fairground turned
to mud and the stage sink though they
had to cancel the whole know they'll
[ __ ] reschedule it he you know once
it all blows over I know but that's how
I mean I was gonna go up there cuz that
was like the week after my birthday and
I was gonna go like you know I was gonna
go do a road trip up there and go hang
out my sister a couple days and AMC's
pretended like they're not going out of
business come back they're not but
they're not them I think a lot like I
said and I'm you know we've said this a
million times
I think theaters that stay open are
gonna have to go like the Alamo
Drafthouse yeah kind of route where it's
like a specialty kind of thing where
they have like you know a cafe attached
to it where they do like because I would
totally go to a theater if they had like
if they had double features of like old
cult classics and they had like a whole
themed thing going you could go in
costumes and [ __ ] like that that'd be
super fun because AMC's going like no
we're gonna open back up in July in
places where we can but other people are
kind of trying to do an analysis on what
the [ __ ] they're sand and they're like
they don't see how yeah because they're
on in so much debt yeah I mean yeah and
and they were already struggling before
this happened and they said that I mean
they're they're reopening some of them
like next week or something like that in
California I heard but you can only be
at like 25% capacity and like all this
other kind of stuff which yeah somebody
asks if you an update on any of your
bikes if you have any projects going on
on any of your bikes man [ __ ] bikes
let me tell you something about the
tubules of course they're done I don't
think I'm gonna change much on them on
the the xp9
that was a City cross that I had and it
was it was that
I had that translucent blue air box
cover on top of it I I tore it all down
and repainted the frame the tail and the
swingarm
IPAN does black so I also painted the
front forks black I didn't do powder
coat or anything I just [ __ ] [ __ ]
painted it all right which works but I
think I'm gonna change the think I'm
gonna change the color of the air box
air box and the little front flyscreen
I might go to carbon we'll see which one
the blue one are they on the blue one on
the so pretty though well you can change
out the air boxes not you know I mean
like I'll get like a carbon fly screen
and a carbon air box cover cuz I want a
black one yeah um you should do a red
one yeah and then the the CT the CT 140
is done but I was [ __ ] driving it
around or riding it around us riding it
pretty hard you know it can almost hit
70 that little thing it only weighs 55
pounds and it probably tops out about 67
that's what my friend clocked me at
riding next to me so almost 70 I guess
but the plug fouled and a wire came
loose in the wiring harness I got to go
back in there and pull the entire wiring
harness and solder everything in
together just can't handle the vibration
yeah
and it's a homemade wiring harness that
I that I made for it so it's not stock
you know that I just got everything if I
could wire it up it's simple but I'm
gonna have to solder it together the
little [ __ ] clip things that just
there's too much vibration yeah it rides
good for what it is but still you know
it's it's slow 67 miles an hour it's
small it feels like you're going real
fast but slow it's [ __ ] dangerous
yeah if you pour on a lot of front brake
the front end will bottom out and on the
triple [ __ ] the triple tree that bottom
clamp will [ __ ] hit the tire and
you'll cut a flip I've cut a flip on it
and coming up through
damn driveway if I can put a bunch of
brake on it and it flipped over on me I
wasn't going fast and I was able to
catch the bike it only weighs 55 pounds
so in number that it didn't touch the
ground I did yeah bike came down just
grabbed it kept me from scratching the
paint because the paint's [ __ ]
bad-ass on it I can enter that bike into
you're like no I'd rather break my arm
yeah only weighs 55 pounds it doesn't
win now the other one that I was working
on was a an RD 350 it's got an inverted
front end on it it's got new [ __ ]
shocks it's got a [ __ ] extended swing
arm I just got the rolling chassis Xin
the tank and the tail alright now I have
I have the bottom into that motor I have
a top end but it's shot and I have a
crank but it's shot so what I was gonna
do is I was gonna get the crank Pistons
in the top end off of a [ __ ] Banshee
which is a you know two stroke to stroke
four-wheeler you could also get a
snowmobile top end and put that on there
the biggest expense would be the [ __ ]
the headers with the expansion chambers
you need a special tuned expansion
chamber if you're gonna do this and I
was gonna [ __ ] get that thing up to
like try to tune it for near a hundred
horsepower which has been badass in
event dangerous though but that's I
probably would have just like I said it
was just a project I probably would have
ridden it that much because I have
modern motorcycles yeah it would have
been at that time I was [ __ ] with it I
was more into it
lately I've kinda gotten lazy um working
out took over I spent a lot of time just
being [ __ ] sore and healing up taking
drugs [ __ ] have to take I have to
take a lot of em K which is you know if
like an Austrian and
I take red 140 which is I took that hot
stream for a while - but man it tastes
like gasoline yes oh it's so bad
Psalms which you know they speed healing
it's not as much as [ __ ] steroids but
it's better than not taking it yeah and
rad does weird things to you if you take
it too long you start getting [ __ ]
suppression and [ __ ] but that's another
cadets love you if I don't want to hear
that [ __ ] we had a couple more questions
do we ever ride the bikes together um I
used to ride on the back of it every now
and then and he tried to like show me it
like teach me how to ride the motorcycle
is no injury I was too scared a [ __ ]
well because I'm super clumsy and it's
like I just feel like I would probably
panic and like kill myself on this [ __ ]
and I was like endeavoring hurt
endeavoring I don't even like to drive a
car yeah I mean I do but I don't like to
I was kind of endeavoring to teach her
back before I knew her all that will now
that I know her I don't shouldn't be on
a motorcycle yeah see you know she
freezes under [ __ ] from stress
physically freezes yeah goes flying a
drone around and it was come out and I
said get it get it and get it she just
sat there and watched that drone hit her
I didn't know it was like I didn't
really see it I just sat on the corner
of my eye because I didn't we were
looking right at it
I wasn't looking right you just you
steered it right into my arm because I
was just you I think I thought for a
second I was like is he really gonna
just steer that right into Syria I lost
control over it and I say get it get it
get it yeah I got him a drone for his
birthday which is July 1st yeah and it
came in the you know in a box obviously
and I was gonna like wrap it and give it
to him on his actual birthday but he
just like opened the box even though it
had my name on it so I was like oh happy
right if I see a box I know what
happened was is we had been waiting for
the New York we thought it was the show
and when it showed up I said oh they're
here and you she was like yeah okay and
then open it up and it was I didn't well
because I did run a notification so I
didn't think that that was coming yeah
that's why I thought it was the RGB so
did she
yeah
and I really had time to fly it yeah
there's a bunch of [ __ ] you gotta do
it's a tree it's got a camera on it
because we want to I mean we wanted to
get one this is like it's not like a
hugely hugely high-end one but I just
wanted it to beginner one yeah that had
like a camera on it so we'd get used to
using one so we could like have some fun
shots for the show yeah aerial shots and
stuff yeah yeah yeah well you know if I
if I'm gonna get like a drone I'm gonna
buy a [ __ ] good drum like [ __ ]
2,000 thousand dollar [ __ ] drone
something that can do weird [ __ ] and
something you have to get licensed
licensed you know what I mean yeah if
I'm gonna give good drone it's gonna be
like a [ __ ] professional grade girl
oh yeah like I said I figured this would
just be a good starter one so we could
figure out how we're it's like how often
we use it and all this other kind of
stuff because I don't want to spend like
you know hundreds and hundreds of
dollars on one that we never use and
then we never use it or we can't figure
it out or doesn't work for what we
wanted to do with it or anything mom
wishes Zachary asked if we had heard of
the Final Fantasy 7 cult which I hadn't
but it's like I wrote it down because I
wanted to look it up and maybe possibly
do a show about it Final Fantasy 7 I
think I played that one wasn't that it
wasn't that one available like on it's
some kind of culture see kind of a
warning I don't come on I had that for
n64 or old PlayStation 1 or something
might have been in Final Fantasy 4 I
don't remember the Final Fantasy
there was a one of those Final Fantasy
games came out and it was it was the
first one I played this is back in the
90s yeah let's been around 98 99 hey is
that angel nine-one-one awakened angel
yeah hey how are you we know we never
yeah in real life so I played that one
and for the time it was pretty cool had
pretty cool graphics but it's just a
button game everything's about timing
and then there's a story you gotta go
think about that yeah you have really
good timing it starts it started to get
kind of repetitive I didn't really find
any super good home video games back in
those days until I got a n64 and there
was like a couple on there that I
[ __ ] love I love Goldeneye
I [ __ ] loved um was the other one
link
[ __ ] the Ocarina of Time yeah that
was a good one yeah I liked
Zelda games and lanes cuz I have played
video games probably in a really long
time I used to like I mean when I used
to have coordination I used to actually
really like Castlevania and sonic
hedgehog and all that kind of stuff but
yeah that's that's dating along I was
like a long time ago I liked waiting all
that all the old Dhoom series doom 64
was good yeah I remember playing I think
I played the first doom like on my PC
like back in the 90s and I remember like
in that because it was like easy you
should walk around shooting zombies yeah
I mean I can handle that it's just I
mean when there's ones that have like 50
million things like flying at you at
once I used to be good at that when I
was a kid but I don't you know I'm not
really good at it anymore um somebody
wait there was something that I wanted
to answer I wish oh I wish I could live
in Florida um it's most of the time it's
cool what I don't like about it cuz I
was born here I do not like hot weather
the heat yeah at all and it's not just a
case of like oh it's hot outside it's
like it's literally just soul-crushing
yeah it's muggy it just feels like it
just feels like a hot towel just like
sitting on your face so at all times
sucks the life out it really does it
just sucks the energy right out of you
and [ __ ] man I went out for a walk and
it's only June right which isn't even
like the hottest part of the summer
that's usually July in August I went out
for a walk at 7 o'clock this morning and
it was already like really really really
muggy and it's really really hot like it
was already approaching 90 degrees and
so I'm walking out there and he just
like sweat buckets like so you just feel
like you have swamp ass like there's a
four seven famous youtuber name called
Benjamin is sargon of akkad he's the
English guy and he came down here and
brought his family up the street here to
[ __ ] Disney World and he did a video
out on the damn patio over overlooking
the swamp and everything and he just
couldn't he just couldn't believe how
[ __ ] hot it was she said it was
literally literally like being stuffed
down Satan's ass crack that's it that's
an accurate it's like being in a sauna
but you can't leave it you can't leave
it it's like there's somebody locked you
in a sauna and you just have to stay in
it and yeah and even right riding a
motorcycles a [ __ ] charge it says boy
well yeah it is very moist and it's just
I'm just can't live here without air
conditioning your mold and mildew would
take over your [ __ ] carpets would rot
your your your your walls would turn
black with mold I don't know how people
lived here back before AC I don't know
either I used to ask my grandmother that
because she moved down here in 1958 and
their house they had they never had
central air at their house I don't know
if it does now because somebody else
lives in it now because she passed away
many years ago but um she just had like
a window unit but when they first moved
down here for years and years they
didn't have any air conditioning and I
was like how did you not die yeah and
she just said oh I don't know it's like
it just didn't seem as hot back then or
it just didn't seem to bother her I
don't really know every piece of paper
would become wrinkly yes everything's
wet the carpets would rot the carpets
would just smell like a damn cat box the
construction of the houses were
different even back in Mississippi you
know I mean there are some old houses we
called him I was in the a/c business off
and on you know if I can when I go to
Mississippi sometimes for like summers
you know my dad's friends would own
[ __ ] central air companies you know
and they called him money eaters and
that was his old Victorian houses yeah
and those houses were built long before
air-conditioning and because the way
they were built it was a lot better okay
then it not it not as good as a modern
house with a/c but a modern house
without AC they're just not designed to
not have air-conditioning yeah it's
[ __ ] miserable but the old houses
they had much higher ceilings each room
had a bunch of tall windows that almost
went all the way down to the floor and
almost all the way up to the ceiling
they were tall long skinny windows there
was no carpeting they were just built to
survive moisture and you could open up
all the windows and get ventilation
through him yeah the modern house you
just can't do that yeah you know so well
even here in Florida I wouldn't open I
mean that's why we have screens but it's
like I wouldn't open the window
anyway because one sceetos well
mosquitoes flying cockroaches which
somebody mentioned here in the comments
also it's like a lot of times even if
you have a breeze in the summer which
you usually don't it's hot breeze so
it's not making it any cooler in your
house evidently and evidently in the
1800's and in the 1900s there were
screens yeah I think there were screens
there must have been because because
they did open the window so I'll just
sit out somewhere Mouse's sit outside
they opened the windows and there would
have been lights in their gas lamps and
lanterns moths would have flown right in
yeah the cockroaches and mosquitoes yeah
it's like no thank you
no all the houses all the beds had
mosquito nets over them big canopy beds
yet you know everybody had that well
yeah you couldn't smile without it but
yeah you get [ __ ] how could you live
how could you have lived back then
comfortably with all your doors and
windows up where all your windows up
they had to have screens yeah so we can
check up on me for that but I would
think they probably had some kind of not
uh silk screens or some kind of weird
nylon so I don't think they didn't have
nylon in the nineteen hundreds and
hundreds no that's it that's a fairly it
must have been some kind of a silk
screen or something yeah some yeah
somebody says take a shower three days
later still not dry exactly it's like
you take a shower even in the
air-conditioning and you get out and
you're still like sticky this is why I
don't really like because I have really
long hair I usually have it up and it's
really long and it's really really thick
so when I wash it it you know it takes
like forever to dry and it's just like
sticks to like every single thing is
skin and it drives me [ __ ] crazy it's
not even this hot in Brazil yeah not
even close it's just the only other
place I think in the world that is like
this the compared to this would be kind
of like probably Mekong Delta in Vietnam
yeah yeah it's just like a horrible
swampy yeah you know yeah somebody says
move to the desert Oh like desert
deserts yeah they like the farthest out
there have been to Colorado and I've
been to Santa Fe like um you know so
that's kind of desert II it's so even
when it's hot there it's like not it's
hot but it's not like here when I was in
the Army you know is deployed the Sinai
in Sinai we were out there in [ __ ]
Sinai desert where the damn Egypt
the Egyptian civilization was you know
not in Egypt and it was [ __ ] hot man
maybe like 120 degrees 30 degrees but
zero percent humidity gives a shade it's
all right when that bad no I mean it's a
totally different kind of heat yeah it's
a dry heat yeah and your sweat glands
keep you cool the way they're supposed
to they don't work out here when you're
immersed in this kind of [ __ ]
humidity sweat doesn't do anything it
just sits there sits there and like
holds it all in it's like being wrapped
in a damn plastic sheet yeah that's what
I mean it's like it's like yeah it's
like being a plastic wrap
yes it's like it can't play can't go
anywhere go it doesn't right there um
okay somebody asked what my natural hair
color is it's actually uh red like a
like a coppery orange II red type of
color although I've been dyeing it black
for so long that it's probably great at
this point I don't really know um so he
also asked Zachary also asked do we know
where our ancestors came from yeah
your Ireland right yeah well you know
that's all about the same thing
Ireland England you know well God yeah
Germany France it's all that my mother
said your family I think was our Ireland
but I did my maternal DNA like a long
time ago and apparently I'm from the
haplogroup that comes from like right
around the turkey region yeah that's
another thing my my granddad on my
mother's side him and his brother were
adopted they came out of an orphanage so
there has s tree was kind of in question
they they kind of believed that they
were part Syrian or part middle-eastern
yeah
but they just look like everybody else
yeah that's just you know and my dad's
side of the family where there's a bunch
of Irish and German names yeah but for
some reason they believed that they were
parsed Syrian yeah my dad side of the
family was part Irish and then my
great-grandmother was actually Native
American Blackfoot so somebody asked
what
should I forgot already Oh somebody's
then flying cockroaches I've never seen
one no thank you yeah you really yeah
they're like that big yeah they're big
and there's well there's a version that
flies and a version that doesn't fly and
they're both like really really big and
really gross they live in trees
well the flying ones live in the trees
like because they're palmetto bugs is
what my grandmother always called them
so they don't live in your house but
they'll come in if you have like your
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah or if it's raining
out they'll come in if it's raining that
you see them a lot in this summer the
other ones the ones that don't fly but
are just as big and just as disgusting
those ones will infest your house like
they live in your house yeah the worst
ones are the little German ones yeah
little German cockroaches and I think
they have those kind of everywhere like
the big ones they just that's mostly
just like a tropical thing it's like a
dinosaur type version of them cockroach
it's like a flattened out reddish
[ __ ] grasshopper
I saw I saw this [ __ ] okay so this is
a long time ago like I think it was God
this is back in the 90s or something I
was watching this like comedian and they
were talking about Florida bugs I think
it was Paula Poundstone actually and she
said you drop a brick on a floor and a
bug and it's like the brick starts to
move and now the bug has a weapon that
is pretty accurate I have dropped one of
those big like unabridged Webster's
dictionaries on because I'm not touching
the [ __ ] okay cuz they're gross and I've
dropped one of those on it to squish it
I picked up the dictionary still alive
damn still alive and that was that
dictionary must have weighed at least 10
minutes dream before uh 41 minutes okay
crap audio synched everything looks good
guys everybody everybody said it looks
good and everybody says the lights look
look good okay
Zachary says their spiders not an issue
in Florida now we got spiders too we
have all kind of spiders
yeah and some of them are [ __ ] huge
Black Widow yeah fires we got type of
spider where the ass is the size of a
ping-pong ball yeah and when they fall
and hit the ground you can hear them go
and it goes yeah run away they're funny
bothered by spiders the cockroaches is
the only thing that bothers me spiders
don't bother me like well I don't even
know like those big
huge ones are not poisonous my
grandfather because we used to see them
in his house along with rats and many
other things because like I said he was
a hoarder
but um we had these big huge spiders he
called the basement spiders but I don't
think that that's what their name is
yeah but they're they're not poisonous
or anything like that but they're like
hella big but they're alarming because
they're big but other than that I'm not
bothered by spiders for some reason just
cockroaches grossed me out more than any
other thing I'm not bothered by any
other kind of bugs other than that other
than those I'm not really sure why that
is
oh I wanted to say to that speaking of
wildlife yesterday out on the path when
I was out doing my doing my power walk
in the morning I saw a little baby near
a little fawn with little speckles and
everything hopefully it didn't like lose
its mom because it was kind of like on
the path and I thought it was a Doberman
because you know from far away and then
I saw it and I was like Oh where's your
mom little guy and it kind of ran down
into the woods by there where there's
like a little swamp there something like
that's maybe mom's down there what's
going on anymore yeah I mean you know
all everything everybody says looks
great everything's good okay well that's
good and that means that we've streamed
for almost 45 minutes and there doesn't
appear to be any problem so you will be
able to do an actual episode like this
yeah it'll probably work out then for
yeah hours I can livestream my walks
that'd be really boring probably oh you
know unless you unless we see stroller
kitty or we see an otter or something
like so the only thing you have to do is
we have to set it up for monetization
and we have to be able to set it up to
give people a notice in other words a
message yeah of when the live stream
will start well have we decided are we
gonna do it tomorrow evening or Saturday
evening how much would you rather have
on you I do t it doesn't matter okay
well it will probably do it tomorrow you
think I would think cuz that's usually
when we record the shows so once you do
at lunch Friday once you cook up a
thumbnail for the notification okay you
know what I mean yeah and then set up
monetization and we'll see how long it
takes to get that approved well the
channels already
I don't think there'd be a problem yeah
I don't think it well I don't think
it'll be like what is yeah that's the
only thing it's no because that was a
verification and I did that like a long
time ago okay so I don't think I don't
foresee any issues but we'll see if
somebody says add super chats okay so I
get a looking to do yeah super chase
that's right yeah so we get yeah we got
to do that oh and he says no Saturday
please maybe we should do it saturday
like as one guy who you may oh yeah
why Saturday well I don't know I was
that's what I was thinking
I don't know I don't know if we should
do it Saturday just because you're not
gonna be able to get everybody on the
same days just that's true I mean I am
gonna put up the [ __ ] later like as an
episode
it's another yeah yeah you'll still be
able to watch it yes you might not be
able to watch it in real time
yeah but yeah I just I was saying Friday
because that's like when we usually
would record it anyway yeah and I just
so we're already used to like doing [ __ ]
on Friday night we'll just do it live
it's yeah and I'm I gotta get my drink
on man yeah and it angel you still on
there angel I haven't seen yeah there
she is
saturday is better for me she says
somebody says I'm off Saturday night we
got to get angel on as a [ __ ] guest
one of these days we'll have her here
because angels into all that Illuminati
world because that's what we're gonna be
talking about late summer night yeah
she's gonna be into that hopefully even
though like you know I've been trying to
do I've been trying to do like research
and stuff but I got it's funny because
the week of our 200th episode when I was
like hoping I would have all this extra
time to like do all this stuff and then
I got like three like humongous like
graphic design projects and I'm just
like trying to get them done and it's
taking forever it's like so I haven't
had as much time to do as much but you
know what I mean it's like whatever
we're just gonna talk about silly
conspiracy theories and Illuminati and
reptilians and stuff and get drunk and
really no one will care all that much
because it's like I'm gonna talk about
David Hickey yeah or how the [ __ ] do you
pronounce I Dickie
I think it's Ike I've heard people
pronounce it but it looks like Nick or
Ikey
this is my mentioned there's a million
ways that we that dude is a little loon
yeah I saw him do one of his little I've
going through this damn projector on the
background you know you know I mean he's
projecting it in front of the audience
and there's actually like reptilian
people pictures ever tell you people get
a with Pope hats on and [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] crazy I think a lot of that a
lot of people get David mixed up with
[ __ ] uh Alex Jones they don't look
anything alike they see David Icke is
British isn't he yeah it doesn't matter
you know I mean you you're not dealing
with rational people when you're dealing
with the public in general yeah they go
well that's John's lizard people yeah I
mean so that's not the same house Jones
does not believe in lizard people David
Hickey I should know it's probably David
Icke Eeyore iCore however that is his
name he might be the only one that
believes lizard well he can't be the
only one because like there's no you got
followers yeah there's other people
making stupid YouTube videos about you
look and look at this person looked all
weird like didn't they so like Eminem or
something like that look he like spaced
out for a second that means he's a
lizard person I was like no that just
means he's very very high it's the same
Shiva but it's the same [ __ ] with like
[ __ ] black-eyed children yeah no I
mean oh I saw black-eyed children-- Oh
black-eyed [ __ ] man that's so that's an
internet meme yeah back in the 90s they
were making [ __ ] pictures a little
kid ghosts in the black eyes out yeah
cuz it's a baby you say well what is a
black-eyed children-- you know they're
treating it like it's it's a unique
sighting well if you were having some
kind of a paranormal event poltergeists
or ghosts or something like that or
demonic [ __ ] possession they could
make you see anything they want to make
you see yeah they're in something like
that
so what is a black-eyed child a ghost
yeah listen Asians we're not real clear
on that's not quick it's just it just
sounds scary just sound scary everybody
likes scary stories I like scary stories
because a lot of them I don't believe
they're real speak it all started if you
ask me it started back in the 90s I came
across and a lot of people came across
it this is back in the [ __ ] webtv
days [ __ ] it never WebTV the
[ __ ] click clicking photos in the
[ __ ] discussion groups and [ __ ]
you found a photograph of a little girl
hovering off the [ __ ] ground in a
white dress black hair and her eyes are
[ __ ] black yeah that's that's the
first time I saw a black eyed child and
I think it that's where it came from
not a black eyed pea that's a totally
dear
anybody remember [ __ ] web TV see we
never had Web TV we just went right from
nothing to like well I had my antique or
I had a television yeah and I had an n64
and back in those days buying a laptop
was just amazingly expensive and a
[ __ ] computer was pretty expensive
but you could buy a web TV for like 80
bucks Wow
yeah it was only 20 and it was only 20
bucks a month for the [ __ ] connection
so and then you could have a wireless
[ __ ] had like a wireless keyboard and
everything and it was a whole web TV
community yeah yeah it was kind of cool
very cool that was like the first time I
ever did any online shopping I'm gonna
man this is like straight out of [ __ ]
the running man arms for tonight you
just our future now I remember like I'm
old enough to remember when you had when
you bought a home computer and it was
just like the keyboard and the CPU and
you had to hook it up to your actual
television set because it didn't have a
monitor yeah I remember that
we time I was like Commodore 64 yeah or
that kind of what the [ __ ] do we have we
always got like I said we were kind of
poor so we always had like the off
branch and then you got a Radio Shack
[Laughter]
yeah it wasn't so everything we had was
like that wasn't cheap either though I
know but it was like it was cheaper than
it was just like we never had an Atari
we always had an odyssey yeah yeah we
always had like the offer I had an
odyssey to type stuff although I think
Odyssey actually was better than Atari
in certain ways just it didn't have the
same amount of games yeah you couldn't
get as much and like all the games were
like kind of like Atari knockoff yeah
they're like Atari knockoff games yeah
the graphics are a little bit better on
Odyssey I mean they're all pretty shitty
they were all shooting by today's
but yeah it was just like a bunch of
little pixels every time I see those
[ __ ] video games that work because if
you watch like all of her Harper's
Channel and he goes into you know the
movies and he talks about like the video
game server based on them and stuff and
like eat they had video games based on
like the Indiana Jones movies and it's
like and here's Indiana Jones doing this
any other it's just like five pixels
laid across this way like that's like
okay I gotta go back in time and go look
and see how much it cost
I think Odyssey 2 is the same prizes of
Atari it might have been thank you but I
just remember like just always have a
music option I think it was it's just an
Atari had so much support that it
quickly just became the better system
yeah because you could get all these
[ __ ] games for well yeah because
that's what everybody had yeah I was
somebody mentioned Eyes Wide Shut did
you just order he ordered that it might
be here today so we might actually do a
retro stuff a lot of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Kubrick was talking about [ __ ] Eyes
Wide Shut sure as hell can true didn't
it I'm not gonna say any names we're
gonna I'm not gonna say any names
because they might cut the [ __ ]
stream we all know that island child man
did not take his own life everybody
knows that sha Islands chatting a child
Island man did not take his own life I'm
not concerned about you're not concerned
about she's not concerned Jenny's not a
believer well no it's not so much of
that it's just like well he's dead so
and he was a [ __ ] there's more of
them out there yeah but there's more of
all shitty visible on there what are you
never gonna get rid of all the shitty
people there they they're the alien
people
yeah Abel well I'm a reptilian you heard
it here the more the more you don't
become rich and powerful by being a good
person well yes happen and history shows
that over and over again so these people
running the show they're bad well they
have for generations I know like I said
that since the beginning and they don't
like these laws that they put on us
those laws are for [ __ ] suckers
really they're just for us we're the
peasants and they have little private
islands and they own other countries and
they go other places to do what bad [ __ ]
and then they come back over here like
they even have guys in the Middle East
because the laws there they have whole
harems of [ __ ] underage girls and
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know famous dudes go
over there go hang out with those guys
down in [ __ ] Saudi and one of them
was a bill Bill Clinton he's friends
with a Saudi [ __ ] Sheikh for [ __ ]
billions of dollars and he's got a whole
hair I'm a little [ __ ] teenage brides
you know and somebody asks if we watch
the Netflix documentary now I have a
watch say yeah I am gonna I am gonna get
around to it I don't know if it's good
or not I would I would expect it to be
probably [ __ ] if it's on Netflix I'd
probably think there's a totally
sanitized version of the story although
I haven't seen it yeah I'm sure there's
a lot of [ __ ] missing because some of
the guys involved in that [ __ ] Island
were powerful [ __ ] people out of the
British royal family and you know
powerful oligarchs powerful people in
the [ __ ] medical industry and they
owned all these [ __ ] media angel said
she watched it it's pretty good because
they're pretty good alright just that
I'm surprised I'm surprised that I'm
surprised that they were allowed to make
that and show that on Netflix they're
all owned by that same class of people
and they cover for each other they all
got dirt on each other it's like a mafia
of people to have dirt on each other
and they're the ruling class they're not
the rich people they're not the upper
class they're the [ __ ] ruling class
they own this earth they created our
ancestors in their industries they see
us as their creations just like out a
[ __ ] a Ridley Scott movie and Kubrick
that's a Kubrick is saying it's true you
guys should do a show on the history of
horror films somebody asked if that
lizard was still living in our wardrobe
no we found him dead
yeah fat fine mountain middle of the
damn carpet and he was had turned black
and I think he died of too cold or
dehydration yeah something like that
back out I tried to I tried to revive
him I put him in some warm water ran
some warm water over and tried
game-2 wake up because he wasn't hard or
anything yeah but he never looked back
up I wonder if like could he have
crawled out there on his own because he
went he crawled out there on his own he
must have I mean I didn't think Pookie
could like get under there and get him
she can't fit under that she hid in
there for about four or five days he was
in there a long time and the air
conditioning kills them
yeah that's why anytime they yeah that's
why we tried if we see them we try to
like giving the hell out of here because
Pookie will bring in frogs in her mouth
to she'll go in the back porch give the
jumping frog and then she'll get like a
little frogs and she won't bring it
inside like because that's her little
friend now and she wants to play with it
tree frogs yeah and so but it's funny
because she knows better because she
knows if we see her bring like a little
frog or a lizard and we'll take it away
from her so she'll try to like stuff it
in her mouth and then like when we open
the thing to let her back she'll look
away she'll look away and like run past
us really fast this is like out into the
living room she's like hey wait a minute
[Laughter]
if she brings a frog in a tree frog
it'll be dead in 12 hours yeah it'll
just dry up as it dries it right out
yeah they can only survive out in that
Digga but ass-crack out there yeah
that's the new name from you out there
the [ __ ] food all right are we gonna
we've been go for an hour maybe we
should maybe we should knock this saucer
no more questions that we I don't think
so I'm trying to like read them but it's
like yeah but yeah we should probably
like you know sign off for the day yes I
got a whole bunch of other projects I
gotta get to you before yeah and now you
know that it works yeah you know what to
setup you got a setup super chance yeah
and and notifications somebody asks do
you ever play yakuza no pretty good I
don't know no I played hitman wants a
long time ago the first one yeah never
played Yakuza yeah I'm not impressing
Yakuza because they're [ __ ]
what am i funny I'm like the sec well I
don't know funny odor but but in a sec
you said that like a whole bunch of
ninjas like just kicked your ass if you
look deep into that damn Yakuza stuff
man those dudes they were here they'd
never survived it could never survive
next to say like the Mexican cartels or
no they did they'd get their asses
kicked
yeah probably yeah well you know oh and
there was in velociter there's ninjas in
that movie too yeah yes good cuz you
know not only do you have like a
dinosaur faster but you have to have
also ninjas and hooker a kung fu hooker
alright so we're gonna wrap it up for
today so have a good rest of your
Thursday and thank you everybody that
turned up we were we didn't think
anybody was gonna we thought we were
just gonna be talking to nobody
yeah so it's like pretty awesome that
you guys all came and then like I said
I'll make an announcement
well we'll decide like whether we're
gonna yeah when a show happens it'll be
a big show do the show like tomorrow
night or Saturday night while many
people Ron there will decide tomorrow um
looks like 43 43 33 yeah it's pretty
good like a short notice on such short
notice yes I said so we'll talk to you
guys probably tomorrow or Saturday so
thanks for dropping by yeah that's good